the united states of america has a
40-year high in inflation and the
federal reserve they are committed to
destroying demand what does destroying
demand mean it means that they're going
to raise interest rates until they
punish the consumer because they don't
want to buy goods or services and they
want to stop borrowing capital
increasing interest rates makes capital
more expensive capital is more expensive
you don't want to borrow it because it
costs you more money and if you're not
borrowing more money it's going to be
sure hard to buy a lot of different
goods and services including things like
houses and we're now seeing the impact
show up in the data mortgage demand has
just hit a brand new 22-year low
interest rates are going up and
inflation is going up and it's
absolutely crushing home buyers if we
take a look inside this article we can
see that mortgage demand fell more than
six percent last week compared with the
previous week hitting the lowest level
since 2000 according to the mortgage
banker association's seasonally adjusted
index applications for a mortgage to
purchase a home dropped seven percent
for the week and were 19 lower than the
same week in 2021 buyers have been
contending with high prices all year but
with rates almost double what they were
in january they've lost considerable
purchasing power now joel kan an
economist for the mortgage bankers
association said purchase activity
declined for both conventional and
government loans as the weakening
economic outlook high inflation and
persistent affordability challenges are
impacting buyer demand now of course if
the federal reserve says they're going
to destroy demand they sure are going to
take a shot at it and they're being
pretty successful so far if you make
capital more expensive people borrow
less people borrow less they buy less
things and so we just had an incredibly
high mortgage demand just last year in
2021 some would say it was historically
high now all of a sudden we have
historically low my big takeaway from
this entire situation is this is what
happens when we have market intervention
we do not have a free market when it
comes to mortgages why was mortgage
demand so high last year it's because
the central bank intervened and they put
interest rates down to zero and they
started buying up assets in the market
that led to a boom in mortgage demand
and people went out and they spent a lot
of money and they pushed home prices
higher sometimes as much as 20 percent
higher on average but now all of a
sudden the federal reserve and other
central banks they're intervening in the
market again they're trying to bring
those interest rates higher and they now
want to be net sellers in the market any
time that you have market intervention
you get some sort of synthetic response
in the market and that's what we're
seeing with a 22-year low in mortgage
demand
ultimately the free market is smarter
than economist the free market is
smarter than central bankers and the
free market is smarter than politicians
they should get out of the way they
should stop intervening and they should
allow the free market to reign if we
went back to free markets we wouldn't
have all this volatility we wouldn't
have historic highs and historic lows
back to back years
ultimately we need the free market
because the free market knows best the
free market would knock off all this
nonsense mortgage demand is low my guess
is once the fed pivots we'll go right
back in the other direction it's like a
roller coaster go up we go down we go up
we go down fed's in control that's not
the way that an economy is supposed to
work that's no way for individuals or
businesses to try to plan their
financial balance sheets and their
investment schedule over the coming
years uncertainty is bad for economies
and the more market intervention we have
the more uncertainties we have and if we
have uncertainty that means we've got
fear and fear that rules everything
around us so ultimately we need the free
market that'll help smooth out a bunch
of this mortgage demand and it'll get us
back to a normal economy where actually
people can learn how to protect their
wealth make money and just live a chill
life
knock it off folks let the free market
rain